let's get to roddy's top five takeaways
mahomes and josh allen i feel like we
could start nowhere besides that this
next generation of quarterbacks those
two continue to show how special they
can be
brother let me tell you something i had
an opportunity to play against some
really really great special quarterback
steve young
um john elway you know kurt warner
peyton manning the list goes on you can
go back dan marino all those guys man
and what we saw
on sunday what we were able to witness
the greatness of these two young guys
and think about it man these guys are in
their low 20s these guys are 20
something years old out there competing
on the highest level like we talk about
competition and the spirit of
competition but imagine those two guys
were the two best players on a planet at
their respective positions and that's
something special man not a lot of
people can say that and to see them out
there competing seeing out there see
them out there going toe-to-toe and josh
allen is an absolute dog let me tell you
something i was so disappointed in that
defense and look i'm a patriot but i
respect the heck out of the buffalo
bills and i respect the heck but
you talk about josh allen when they need
it most what is he gonna do he's putting
his body on the line six five two for
240 250 he gets it done i mean he could
do everything look at that little
sidearm pass right to cole beasley
this dude deserved to be in the super
bowl and because of that defense because
of some stupid mistakes and then playing
a bend but don't break mentality with
leslie frazier and sean mcdermott this
guy is not playing for the afc
championship the way he played he
deserved to be in the championship game
and if i'm josh allen i am absolutely
sick to my stomach right now because
they they deserve to be in this game
some of the most amazing scramble plays
that i've seen in forever i mean he's
making the best defenders on that kansas
city defense melvin ingram maybe it's
clark on another play he's just making
him miss right he's making a miss and
he's scrambling and then he makes the
next guy miss and then he's setting his
feet he's ripping a throw i mean how
about that two-point conversion where
he's buying six extra seconds and then
throwing a missile to the back of the
end zone it's amazing so then when you
flip it to the other side of things and
you got the kansas city chiefs in the
grim reaper that patrick mahomes could
be i mean there's 13 seconds remaining
on that clock they left 13 seconds it
flashes me back to that bengals game
where they're going forget it on fourth
and one we're going for this we're not
giving mahomes any chance to get the
football back you see why because with
13 seconds he can do that kind of damage
yeah with 13 seconds defensively if i'm
the defensive coordinator what i'm
telling my guys is hey we're going to
play a soft coverage we're going to play
a soft coverage right first of all i'm
not i'm not kicking the ball to these
guys but if i do we're not going to play
a soft coverage we're going to get up
we're going to jam these guys around the
30-yard line and who gives them that
much space you can't give that's an
extra 18 yards now all of a sudden you
have kelsey down here you're playing
soft coverage you don't touch them you
don't jam them you got to slow them down
and then it sets up the winning field
goal
i don't know for the life of me this is
the number one defense in the national
football league and this is something
you practice
damn there every day you practice this
situation almost every day and for the
buffalo bills to play such a soft
conservative approach leslie frazier
you've been around the game you you were
with my 85 super bowl bears like i
respect you but you cannot play defense
soft in that situation you got to get up
you got to jam those guys you got to
throw them off their route you got to
jam them slow them down an extra two or
three seconds run off the clock but you
cannot just let patrick mahomes drop
back let these guys run down the field
unencumbered you don't touch them and
then all of a sudden you know now you're
at home watching the freaking afc
championship game coming up this weekend
it's it's it's terrible jack
josh allen because you just won the game
time and time again just one impossible
drive after impossible drive and they
always ask him to do it all himself and
he just kept doing it all himself
himself himself and even just watching
him over there on the sideline the look
on his face was just like he just
couldn't believe that they couldn't give
him one chance i'll tell you what else
was really cool rod for me was listening
to travis kelsey uh they did the miked
up thing right had him miked up that
whole final drive and his leadership
talking to patrick mahomes going hey
first first of all they had to hit that
play to tyreek hill right they hit the
screen that set up the next play to
kelsey to put him in range he tells
tyrique hey tyrek start outside and then
come back under me it'll give you
ability to get more space boom boom
tyree gets all the yards next play he
goes and tells my homes he goes mahomes
if they're playing this coverage that
seems going to be wide open and you can
hear patrick mahomes right before the
snap go hey kelsey do it do it do it if
you listen close to that game copy
kelsey do it once you do that seem they
put it right on the money so to see the
leadership we talk a ton about patrick
mahomes and what he means from that
quarterback spot because he does but
they see kelsey in the communication and
understanding of defenses that's why
this guy's so wide open it's why he's
patrick mahomes best friend
well that's why this offense works
because you just can't be a guy in this
offense they push you mentally to know
every position they push you mentally to
know why they're doing certain things
why they're trying to set up uh who
they're trying to set up how they're
trying to set them up all those things
and you talk about patrick mahomes i
really truly respect his growth because
let me tell you like coming in whenever
started everybody started playing that
cover two he couldn't adjust he couldn't
just and then finally he really humbled
himself he took to coaching and all eric
b enemy said was like just stay patient
just stay patient if they're gonna keep
two safeties back we're gonna nickel and
dime them to death and once he bought
into that it just changed the whole
mentality of him it also changed the old
mentality of the offense so now
everyone's saying wow we can play cover
two we can keep them from making a big
play but
they're 12 plays 75 yards and it's just
growth not only as a quarterback but
growth as an offense and that's a big
part of why they're having success
in the nfl is just in such good hands
for the next decade you think of these
two quarterbacks i'm looking at the very
end of that game when patrick mahomes
he's running past teammates guys that
are this is one of the most insane nfl
wins if you go through the history of
the league the last four minutes of that
game you're never gonna find a finish
like that and mahomes is running past
his teammates avoiding the celebration
so that he can go give josh allen this
hug to show him the respect of what he
just did what he forced mahomes to
overcome to get this wins it was the
first thing he wanted to do was go show
that respect and that gives you some
idea of not only the players but the
people that we have leading the nfl
right now
let me tell you something man just
that competitive spirit right there just
shows how competitive both those guys
are how much respect they have for one
another and they both understand how
difficult it is to play quarterback in
the national football league these two
dudes are very similar i'm sure josh
steals some stuff from patrick patrick
would steal some stuff from josh and
these these guys will be competing like
you said for the next decade or so so
really exciting to see
to our second takeaway which is deebo
sandville you watch this game they just
ask him to do everything and you get you
get to see why shanahan talks so highly
about debo sam he's playing running back
he's returning kick he's playing
receiver so it begs the question is this
the best play maker in the nfl right now
and you look at the versatility and
things he's able to do
i would say best and most dangerous
definitely because i mean like he's a
big dude like we're out there his legs
like tree trunks like huge legs and this
dude is fast like you see him at
university south carolina when i watch
him play
you like okay this dude is kind of fast
what is this 40 time
and like he keeps breaking tackles like
even against um
the last week he caught a sl he caught
it like a wide receiver hitch made a guy
miss and went 20 something yards it was
just a hitch made two or three guys miss
and it went 20 something yards so now
as a defense you're trying to figure out
okay where's he at
is he at running back is he in slot is
he at the wide receiver spot how are
they going to use him so it puts a lot
of pressure on the defense to try to
identify him try to figure out where
he's at and then trying to get him but
yeah he is definitely the most dangerous
because he can do it all and he he
brings that that physicality he gives
them their identity on the offensive
side of the ball then you add in trent
williams left tackle you add in george
kittle and you add in elijah mitchell
this is why this team is so physical
this is a wide receiver running over
people running through linebackers
running through safeties running through
corners and everybody knows he's going
to get the ball and when he gets the
ball look at his teammates blocking 10
15 yards down the field he's just a very
special special player and when it comes
contract time he better tell him hey i'm
not just a wide receiver i'm a playmaker
so you're gonna have to break bread
period because you have to pay me a lot
of money
those are the facts and when you look at
what the final four is it's three of the
four are quarterback driven teams right
you got borough you got mahomes you got
stafford and that fourth team is just a
badass physical beats you up push you
around san francisco 49ers team and it's
been the kryptonite for some of these
awesome offenses right it's been the
kryptonite for the green bay packers
it's been the kryptonite for the los
angeles rams and it may wind up being
that again it always feels like this to
me rod when you get to this point in the
year and it's cold weather football and
these great quarterbacks the one thing
that can neutralize is the teams can get
after the pastor with four and the way
that the 49ers can just bring four and
just make life miserable on aaron
rodgers he's back there sometimes he's
trying to scramble now bose has got him
by the ankles because he's so athletic
those are the one kryptonite matchup
that i've seen it seems like every
playoff and right now that team to me
feels like the san francisco 49ers
well you look at san francisco you look
at the rams man both of those teams have
those guys we witnessed it right right
there we were first and we're looking at
aaron we're looking at aaron donald
we're looking at von miller and those
guys and just how fast they get the pass
rush how fast they break down their
pocket protection and and the 49ers got
some big dudes dj jones up in there
those guys are big they're athletic they
they do great job of stunting they just
they get after you man they play
physical and those linebackers oh my
goodness those linebackers i share and
um fred warner those guys are fast
they're athletic they're very physical
and those secondary guys they're they're
solid across the board so it wouldn't
surprise me if san francisco
ended up in the super bowl it just
wouldn't surprise me man this is a very
physical team
it wouldn't surprise me either you
mentioned fred warren that big punch he
had on mercedes lewis to get the ball
loose he is an instinctive linebacker
athletic he sees it he's so fast it's
exactly right so let's get to our third
takeaway because we just came out of
tampa right we were up there we've seen
the 28 to three we all know the atlanta
falcons story this was 27 to 3 and it
never felt like the game was over it
just always felt like brady would have a
chance and of course so many wild
moments happened to where tom brady can
crawl back into this thing and now the
question becomes after the loss will tom
brady play in 2022 let's hear from tb12
this is what he said on his podcast the
tb12 podcast i think i'll clean it up
that's not the name of the podcast the
let's go podcast here's what he had to
say about the potential of his future
well i think the point is there's no
really rush for me to uh to figure out
what's next you know i'll know when i
know
and um it's too it's a day after the
season so i think for all of us
you know we can all decompress a bit
it's been six straight months of
football every day consumed by you know
day in and day out football and i think
now it's just some time to
spend some time with my family and spend
some time with you know my kids the
biggest difference now that i'm older is
i have kids now too
you know and i care about them a lot as
well you know they've been my biggest
supporters
my wife is my biggest supporter
you know it pains her to see me get hit
out there you know she deserves what she
needs from me as a husband my kids
deserve what they need from me as a dad
you know i'm going to spend some time
with them and giving them what they need
because they've really been giving me
what i need the last six months to do
what i love to do and
you know i said this a few years ago
it's
it's what relationships are all about
it's not always what i want it's what we
want as a family and uh you know i'm
gonna spend a lot of time with them and
you know figure out
in the future what's what's next
man that's that's really well said and
it's a lot to break down but the one
thing i want to
talk about is
you know just
those times man are very special that
you mess in the morning with your kids
like i get a chance to wake up with my
daughter and my kids my boys you know
whether i fix some breakfast or drop her
off at school that's my five minutes
that's my 10-15 minutes with her and
that's something that you just can't get
back when you're playing football when
you're up at 5 00 a.m you're walking out
the house by 5 15 and they don't see you
until seven eight o'clock at night
that's those are the things that you
miss those recitals and you know being
able to go up to the school and see your
daughter at 12 o'clock and sit down and
have lunch with her those are the things
he's talking about you never get that
back football is fine and dandy and it's
great but at the end of the day you
don't get that opportunity to take your
wife out to lunch at 12 o'clock or 1
o'clock in the afternoon and those are
very very special moments and it's not
tom's not the only one
sacrificing
your family sacrifices a lot too because
everything is built around your football
schedule everything's built around you
so what tom is saying is basically as a
husband he's like look my family
supported me through this entire time
now it's time for me to spend time with
them and we figure it out and he spot on
after football six months you have a lot
of emotional things that's going on in
your mind in your brain and you need
time but if i would if if i had to say
something i do believe that tom might
give it one more shot he might give it
one more shot if i had to guess because
i know tom doesn't really want to go out
the way he went out um but i would say
at the end of the day he's going to talk
it over with his family and and we'll
know soon
yeah you could tell for the last few
years that this was going to be a group
decision and i think tom has adapted his
life the last few
to make sure that he's being you know
having a two-pronged life that he's
spending his time with his family
prioritizing that and he's prioritizing
football i think they wanted to come
south have a little better life a little
better weather all those things so i
think it's been part of this new tom
brady formula if it were totally up to
tom i think he would play next year i
don't think it's totally up to tom
though and that's why i have no clue
what's gonna happen but here's to me
what happened to the bucks this year
right tom brady came down to tampa and
he built an all-star team he built an
all-star offense they had a great
defense too awesome offensive line five
guys across the line who were just studs
and then the play makers looked like a
pro bowl team right you had a b you had
godwin you had evans you had scottie
miller they were so deep you had gronk
you had three talented tight ends great
you name it right good running backs out
of the backfield they could catch all
those things
and then new orleans came to town and
they roughed this team up in ways that i
didn't even know was possible god one
gets taken out he's done for the season
leonard fournette gets hurt in that game
that game just sucked the life out of
this team and then on the heels of it a
b decides that he's just gonna go nuts
so to me that's what happened he came
down here he built an all-star team and
it just crumbled right before the most
important point of the season so now
does he want to go play gm tom brady and
rebuild it all over again perhaps he
does but it's going to take a whole lot
of work because my guess is godwin
probably is not going to be there
anymore a b is not going to be there so
he's going to have to get very creative
if he wants to rebuild all that it was
you said that it crumbled man they just
played the divisional game they all they
were they were a play away from
basically being in the nfc championship
so it didn't crumble it's just things
happen and that's why it's so hard to
let me just say it's very hard to repeat
what's that
saying they got beat pretty good in that
game i understand he put together a
miracle comeback and nobody's better
than brady but they got handled pretty
darn good in the first half of that game
yeah absolutely but all i'm saying is
this they were still very competitive
the biggest thing that i saw outside of
the injuries and you're spot on jack
you're not you're not wrong for what
you're saying you're spot on actually
but one thing that i saw i just saw
complacency i saw a team that
they weren't as hungry as they were
last year they just weren't you know you
saw you saw guys like devin white doing
their own thing antoine whitfield came
to me before the game i went up and said
hey what's the most important thing you
got to do he says
well we got to protect the deep part of
the field because you know i'm like yeah
you know matthew stafford's going to
take shots down there against you guys
and what get what happens
they get beat for a 70-yard touchdown
you know by cooper cup it's but it's
those things and to me tom's going to
take a look at the the roster he's going
to look at the defense he's going to
look at the offense and see if is this
something that i can come back to is
this something that i can compete
because he's not going anywhere else can
we win a championship with this roster
if he believes so i think there's a
chance that he might but at the end of
the day i know his wife is in that
situation where you don't want to try to
and at the end of the day force your
husband to kind of walk away from the
game even though you might feel like
it's in his best interest
you know i think he's just going to
figure it out but at the end of the day
you know they better have tom brady
because if not they don't really have a
backup quarterback plan
if they don't have time it might be
bruce may retire bruce erians may retire
i mean it may just be the end of this
run i mean i think we all understand get
to the fourth one and there's no special
teams opinion i value more than yours
because your whole career you wanted to
play special teams you voluntarily
played special teams even when you were
a big name rodney harrison so i want to
hear your opinion on what the heck
happened to the green bay packers and
their special teams in this game were a
game or two away from the super bowl
i'm blaming matt laflore matt lafleur is
the head coach and whenever your head
coach comes in and he says special teams
is a priority special teams is just as
important in all of offense and defense
when he comes in and he says that he
makes it a priority to be good on
special teams then you know you're going
to have good special teams all right and
he never made that a priority and it
came back and it bit them in the butt
and it just and they lost games when we
were there they had terrible special
teams but aaron rodgers was so good that
they were able to overcome it the
defense was really good but in times
that the offense is struggling you need
those special teams and they have to be
good and that's matt lafleur's fault he
should have knit that in the butt and
even if he's struggling as far as the
coach you remove him you replace him you
do whatever you have to do to bring
them special teams up to par and i told
you this i told you when the chargers
played against the raiders how important
special teams were and why we as
patriots we volunteered as starters guys
playing 65 70 plays a game we
volunteered because we understood and
knew the importance of field position
making sure that we start at the 20-yard
line as opposed to the 40-45-yard line
when they only need a couple first downs
and then all of a sudden they're in
position to kick a field goal special
teams man it just can't be offense it
can't be defense you have to pay
attention to everything and that's his
inexperience as a head coach not
emphasizing special teams
that's right and the mistakes were
almost everywhere right is the big
kickoff return debo samuel had right at
the beginning of the third quarter going
into halftime they had that field goal
right they had that field goal as well
where lancaster is playing the left wing
and he prioritizes the guy coming
outside and the guy going inside who
obviously has a much shorter lane to get
to the kicker he just lets him be a free
runner and they block that thing right
before the end of half time and it's
those little momentum things i mean this
in every single way should have been a
packers win it should have just been a
slug out drag out packers win and it's
about you know seven to three ten to
three whatever it would have been
garoppolo is not going to go all the way
down the field score touchdown at the
end of that game the packers defense was
playing awesome the one thing you
couldn't have do in the fourth quarter
was a blocked punt that lands on the
goal line is picked up for a touchdown
it's the one thing that you couldn't
have happened and that's how the green
bay packers wind up losing this thing i
just think it's it's such a shame and i
don't know who else you could look at
besides the head coach let's hear from
lefleur and what he had to say after
this one because to his credit he at
least stepped up and took the blame
matt it looked like you guys had 10 guys
on the field for that final field goal
attempt how does that happen in that
moment
um
that can't happen
it's unacceptable
again that's on me
yeah it's extremely disappointing um
especially
you look at that what happened tonight
um
again these are things i i got to do a
better job obviously and be more
involved
um
to make sure that
those types of things don't happen that
we're
putting these guys in the right position
that we're coaching them the right way
and i mean ultimately it all falls on me
it's incorrect it does fall on him
because he's the head coach and he has
to come in he has to emphasize the
importance of special teams and that's
why i love coach belichick because he
says i don't care how many pro bowls how
many all pros you got
if we need you to play special teams
you're going to play special teams and
matt lafleur was so focused on the
offensive side of the ball he hired joe
berry to take care of the defense and he
kind of just left the special teams out
there floating and he's kicking himself
in the bud that's why he and that's the
inexperience of matt lafleur he says
well i have to do a better job i need to
be more involved you're damn right you
need to be more involved you are the
head coach you should be sitting in
those meetings the special teams
meetings
just overlooking everything and you
should bounce your way over to the
offensive side and always communicate
with the defensive
defensive coordinator but you know and
he he's he understands it now so next
year i guarantee you he will be better
in the special teams area
i bet he will too and it's really a
fascinating thing because we've seen
this youth movement of coaches right and
even when you look at the final four
shoot zach taylor who the heck would
have thought he's writing this thing
kyle shanahan has another young coach
sean mcveigh he's hired in his low 30s
right and then you got lefleur who's
another young coach so there's certainly
been this youth movement
infused into the nfl and i think it
started with mike tomlin and it worked
there and he was a defensive coach and
it's now flipped to these offensive
minds to go
really teach these young quarterbacks
what it means to be an nfl quarterback
it seems to be working so why do you
think these young nfl coaches are having
success despite what we're seeing with
leflore where inexperience can bite you
there's both sides of that coin
as well let's take a look at their
quarterbacks
you probably got the best quarterbacks
in the league too right
[Laughter]
like matt leflore you have aaron rodgers
zach taylor you had a dog in joe burrell
like come on man and then matthew
stafford he's proven that i mean what we
knew matthew stafford can play we knew
that he was a tough guy but we wanted
him to prove it on the big stage he's
starting to prove it on a big stage he's
got another big stage he has to prove it
on but yeah it starts with the
quarterback where where would matt
leflore be
right now if he had to go with jordan
love
what would he be we wouldn't be saying
he was coach of the year last year or
you know he wouldn't be in this
situation they probably wouldn't even
make the playoffs with him
but when
great it makes their job easier and
these guys have been given every
opportunity you know and and let's just
put it out there all the coaches that
you name those are young white coaches
they've been given opportunity and black
coaches have not been given and people
have been patient with them and it's not
like they're going to a place that has a
garbage quarterback these guys have you
know franchise quarterbacks so that
matters and you see like you give eric
the enemy joe burrow you give you know
one of those brian lefferts joe burrow
like those are the type of opportunities
and jobs that a lot of these black
coaches need you can't just put them on
a team with no quarterback
that has to happen through this next
coaching cycle and i do think that
there's been a bit of a shift like bill
belichick right all the super bowls you
won with him i'm sure he'll figure out a
way to win another super bowl before
it's all said and done but that old
style of coaching i you don't see many
new coaches being hired who are this
have the same sort of tough way about
them when they get in front of the team
and lead it's now the expectation is
that they want you to be a players coach
and i think it begins with where they
are in college right and the transfer
portal basically every year at the end
of the season it's like open you know
free agency anybody can go anywhere if
they're not happy or they're not getting
treated this way they can transfer and
then by the time they get to the nfl
they expect that you're going to be a
player's coach and i think a guy like
sean mcvay is really one of the first
that i've seen really lock in on just
going the respect and the friendship and
the relationships that he builds with
these players it winds up resulting in
them playing and giving everything right
back to him and i mean you heard odell
beckham jr talk about with chris sims
this week how laid back of an atmosphere
that he creates it's like playing in the
pro bowl right there's all these
talented players but he makes it laid
back because he knows that we all know
what we need to do to get ourselves
ready and so that's work so i do think
that it's really more about finding
players coaches right guys that the
players are going to love and my guess
is this next cycle of head coaching
hires i i really hope that you see a ton
of diversity because that's what it
needs to be but it results in players
coaches right don't you get that sense
that the players have to like you now
for you to really hang on for a long
period of time
no i get the sense that the players have
to respect you okay because you're not
gonna always make a decision that you
know pleases everyone but if you do it
you do what's in the best interest of
the team
then the players are going to respect
you and you have to treat everybody with
respect and everybody's a little
different you know you can't treat
everybody the same okay you give
everyone respect but you can't treat tom
brady the same way you treat the 53rd
guy you just can't do that you hold todd
and brady in a higher esteem it's just
the way it is that's why you pay him 30
million dollars a year you know
um
bay has been great they've they've given
up all these future picks and things
like that and i'm really happy for him
because i do think he's a coach i think
he's very passionate i think he's a very
good coach i think he's very
knowledgeable i think he learned so much
from losing the super bowl um to um
coach belichick and i'm really excited
to see what he comes up with i mean and
you saw you see the stamp of sean
mcveigh like he's been calling some
really good plays like he's put them in
a position offensively
to have success and the way he's
incorporated
odell beckham has been tremendous for
this team
and they're hungry right and we'll get
to that when we start talking about next
game but they're hungry man obj von
miller stafford all these guys that have
never whitworth the left tackle they've
never tasted a super bowl right and the
bucks they had just had it last year so
i just see them as a lot hungrier right
now and they're playing that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports